[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer spezialausgabe von
viertel nach acht ist der 98 kriegstag
in der ukraine wir fragen uns ist
russland noch zu stoppen kann die
ukraine gewinnt ist bundeskanzler olaf
scholz ein zauderer oder ein besonders
staatsmann darüber möchte ich heute
abend debattieren mit meinen großartigen
gästen dem stellvertretenden
bundesvorsitzenden fdp und bundestags
vizepräsident wolfgang kubicki schön
dass sie da sind bild vizekanzler er
berichtete drei monate aus dem
kriegsgebiet in der ukraine und hat als
einziger deutscher journalist mehrfach
den ukrainischen präsidenten selensky
zum live interview getroffen
linken-politikerin seewegen tag den es
seit 2005 mitglied des deutschen
bundestages und heute abend hier bei uns
last but not least weg kennt ihn nicht
kult kolumnist journalist autor und vor
allem für den nach acht stammgast hans
ulrich jörges heute wurde im bundestag
bei der generaldebatte heftig diskutiert
der oppositionsführer friedrich merz
machte seinem ärger über das zaudern von
olaf scholz der ukraine luft der
konterte mit ankündigung weiterer
waffenlieferungen hören wir einmal in
die debatte ein
die kommenden wochen werden wir auch
weitere waffen liefern zum beispiel hat
die bundesregierung aktuell entschieden
dass wir mit dem system iris t das
modernste flugabwehrsystem liefern über
das deutschland verfügt mehr als einen
monat nach dieser gemeinsamen
entschließung im deutschen bundestag
sind der ukraine bis zum heutigen tag
die zugesagten waffen nicht geliefert
worden mehr als einem monat statt dessen
werden von mitgliedern ihrer
bundesregierung herr bundeskanzler und
aus ihrer partei heraus ständig
irgendwelche behauptungen aufgestellt
die schlicht und einfach falsch sind sie
telefonieren 80 minuten mit dem krieg
mit dem russischen staatspräsidenten
und morgen
kommt der
parlamentspräsident der ukraine nach
deutschland nach berlin und sie
verweigern ihm bis zu dieser minute
einen gesprächstermin alles was sie
sagen ist nicht richtig wir machen das
was möglich ist allen rezession mal
herr kubicki sie sind selbst in der
regierung mit der fdp können sie das
ärgernis von herr scholz überschuss von
herr merz verstehen also zumindest kann
ich verstehen dass die oppositionsführer
die rechtliche frage stellt warum wir
mehr als einen monat brauchen wir ein
beschluss des deutschen bundestages der
mit großer mehrheit gefasst worden ist
umzusetzen dafür gibt es bisher auch
keine logische erklärung aber ich bin
nicht teil der regierung ich bin
parlaments vizepräsident teil des
gesetzes die fdp ist teil der rega und
erst als er weit aber
nach wie vor steht immer im raum wir
liefern wir liefern wir liefern wir
kündigen als andere wahrheit das ist
sogar gab es bisher keine keinen
transport von schweren von schwerem
gerät in die ukraine den hätte geben
müssen früher ja zunächst einmal ist die
sprache jetzt im frühjahr geben können
ich glaube dass schon weil wir wie
gesagt sie haben das angekündigt bei den
tag 98 sind man hätte bereits ende
februar sie mit der frage beschäftigen
müssen
wenn die ukraine dem russischen anke
standhält geben wir jetzt rheinmetall
die genehmigungen für ein gefragtes
material instand zu setzen um bis zu
liefern dann wäre es jetzt bereits
geliefert gucken wir bei alldem was die
bundeswehr hat wirklich nach was
brauchen wir unbedingt zur eigenen
verteidigungsfähigkeiten bunten ist und
was ist ihr kurzfristig auch auch
sozusagen lieferbar und ich glaube schon
muss mich darauf die aussagen meiner
verteidigungspolitische sprecherin und
folien des quartalsausweises
strack-zimmermann verlassen die ja
anders als ich auch einblick in geheime
unterlagen hat wenn sie sagt wir hätten
mehr tun können dann bin ich sicher
werden wir tun können freitag den hätten
wir mehr tun können hätten wir mehr tun
müssen steilere waffenlieferungen für
die ukraine die frage ist doch wie
helfen wir den ukrainern am besten und
ich glaube dass mit mehr waffen und
immer mehr schweren waffen wir den
ukrainer nicht helfen weil dir damals
und mit schweren waffen wird der krieg
verlängert kriege werden gefüllt mit
waffen kriege werden aber beendet mit
verhandlungen selbst der us
amerikanische außenminister blinken und
der generalsekretär
der nato haben heute nochmal sagt das
nur mit verhandlungen dieser krieg
beendet wird und ich sehe nur dass wir
seit monaten ständig tagein tagaus immer
nur über waffen und sanktionen sprechen
aber nicht ansatzweise wird energie
darauf verwendet wie können wir einen
verhandlungsfrieden in der ukraine
schaffen damit das leichter das ordnete
entschuldigen sei also aber wenn wir
also auf diesem niveau hier diskutieren
wollen darüber sehen können wie könnte
ich mich gleich verabschieden ronzheimer
aber nichts ist hier anhören dass die
profil den zu bedienen mit ihrem
verlegung das weiß ich wirklich
entschieden zurück und hören sie auf süd
mit dieser kriegspropaganda was hat nur
weiter verwalten jeder der gegen
waffenlieferungen in diesem land ist
dagegen die sanktionen ist wird als
putin troll oder kreml apologet oder
sonst was dieser neuerung lassen 1 3 der
kriegspropaganda das hat mich oft
programmiert und marita reviews das ist
teil des militarismus besser durch
militarismus zu tun hat sagen ich sich
für eine solche klage sondern würde
putin mit seiner armee alle ukraine
töten das ist nämlich ein ziel jeder der
nicht bereit ist in den krieg zu ziehen
gegen den äußeren feind wird hier zum
inneren feind erklärt und das weiss ich
zurück das hat noch über 100 jahre die
neugier ist also hier in denen die gegen
den ersten weltkrieg waren als zaren
versteher diffamiert worden sind wir
sollten wirklich damit aufhören es gibt
ein legitimes interesse von 50 prozent
der bevölkerung in deutschland die laut
umfragen gegen die lieferung von
schweren waffen sind wollen sie
behaupten dass 50 prozent der
bevölkerung hier irgendwie putin
das ist doch absurd das ist wirklich an
drohungen lassen sie uns doch darüber
reden ich sage ich habe meine meinung
ist dass ich das für falsch finde diese
politik der waffenlieferungen und der
sanktionen die eigentlich ein schuss ins
eigene knie sind hier in deutschland
wenn man sich mal die zahlen anschaut
beim öl embargo beim totalen energie
embargo und das über die sanktionen
nicht im jahr aber wenn wir zurückkommen
zu den beide strategien finde ich falsch
waffenlieferungen und auch die
sanktionen ja einfluss wagen keine
überrollen lassen
kriegsverbrechen begehen dass wir da
passen wir keine waffen die wollen sie
jetzt ihr eine show ab
die frage müssen sie beantworten der
russische truppen aufgehalten werden
soll wie ich sagte wir müssten wirklich
versuchen an den verhandlungstisch zu
kommen es gibt sogar den großen jungs
wollen was das halte ich das halte ich
für ein gerücht zum beispiel es gab ja
es gab ja tatsächlich versuche von
istanbul angefangen beispielsweise und
washington post guardian new york times
und viele andere an gesagt dass
besonders die us administration die aber
sehr widersprüchlich ist also meine
kontakte in washington sagen dass es da
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt die
einen haben die linie schreibt zum
beispiel die sagen der kriegt muss
beendet werden und man braucht eine
verhandlungsstrategie
und die anderen sagen wir müssen mehr
waffen eva aber es gab diese versuche
dann muss noch mal zurück und anderer
versuch seine offizielle erklärung putin
selbst auch offiziell erklärt wenn die
ukraine kapituliert dann ist frieden
aber das würde bedeuten sie besetzen die
ukraine mit ihren russischen truppen
auch ohne ihren widerstand dagegen nur
ein handy ist auch in vellmar
vertreibungen dass ein bisschen
sachlicher zu machen statt nur so ein
austausch von emotionen
ich halte es für keinen zufall dass
deutschland noch keine schweren waffen
geliefert hatte ich halte es für absicht
das ist keine unfähigkeit die schweren
waffen die deutschland ja x-mal
angekündigt hat der bundeskanzler muss
man genauer sagen werden nach meiner
auffassung oder sollen nach meiner
auffassung dann geliefert werden wenn es
schon waffenstillstand gibt die sollen
später erst ein treffen und was heute
angekündigt worden ist das
luftabwehrsystem frau bernburg hat
sofort anschließend gesagt wird mehrere
monate dauern bis das geliefert wird
alles dauert mehrere monate auch der
gepa panzer wird erst im juli geliefert
und das war sofort geliefert werden
könnte wird nicht geliefert da sieht man
die absicht hat der der schützenpanzer
marder könnte sofort geliefert da gibt
es auch viele von beständen der
bundeswehr
die werden den ringtausch aktionen die
dann wieder ewig wochen dauern an
griechenland geliefert an tschechien
geliefert die sollen dann kaputte
sowjetische panzer an an die ukraine
liefern das ist alles zu auffällig ich
glaube dass die bundesregierung und
vermutlich auch paris eine strategie
verfolgen sie wollen den zeitpunkt
abwarten der ist ja nicht mehr so fern
dass russland die gesamte ost ukraine
denn don was erobert hat weil dann
vielleicht die chance auf ein
waffenstillstand besteht weil die russen
das erreicht haben was sie als erfolg
ausgeben können plan a ist verliebt die
ganze ukraine zu besetzen gelingt ihnen
nicht mehr plant das ist plan b also die
krim weiter zu besetzen den landwirten
nach russland und die gesamte ostukraine
und dann zu behaupten dass er das
kriegsziel gewesen und ich glaube er
kann ja er kann ja sozusagen den don was
besetzen und sagen wir machen scheint
verhandlung dann machen wir niemand
weiter niemals wieder nach trier das
kann schon sein dass man niemanden oder
jemand weiß ich rede auch nicht darüber
was putin bild das weiß ich nicht
wahrscheinlich nicht mal vermutungen an
aber ich glaube dass die in berlin das
kanzleramt und paris auf diesen punkt
hin arbeiten und deshalb den vormarsch
der unbestreitbar ist russin im donbass
nicht durch neue schnelle
waffenlieferungen aufhalten wollen die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
frau strack zimmermann fdp hat ja
gefordert sofort oder möglichst schnell
besser gesagt marder panzer
schützenpanzer an die ukraine zu liefern
davon gibt es ungefähr 380 in beständen
der bundeswehr das wäre nicht schwierig
uhr
hat dann werden hat neue produziert und
die füllen die reihen der bundeswehr
wieder auf dann wenn man wollte könnte
man man liefert ja auch funktionsfähigem
marder an griechenland und tschechien
aber an dient an die ukraine nicht man
will einfach nicht der kanzler will
nicht ich finde um das mal zu sagen ich
bin so sauer mit dieser für mich
erkennbaren linien der bundesregierung
waffenlieferungen und stücke richtigen
waffenlieferungen wenn man verhindern
will dass die russischen truppen über
die grenzen des donners hinaus wieder an
die ukraine reinkommt muss man sich
ukraine jetzt befähigen dem zu
widerstehen und ich würde eigentlich
erwarten dass jetzt mal der zeitpunkt
kommt man es sieht ja dass die grünen
ganz anderer auffassung sind dass die
fdp durch frau strack-zimmermann auch
anderer auffassung ist die sollen doch
mal welche wirkungsvolles die sonntag
man und wirkungsvolles ultimatum
erklären anstelle der grünen würde ich
mir hoffnung dass uli moment dass die
sagen in 14 tagen werden 50 marder an
die eu vereine geliefert oder diese
koalition ist zu ende das erwarte ich
mal um druck auf scholz habe ich hier
ist ja ein bisschen der punkt und hier
würde ich gern einen punkt von frau da
gehen gerne aufgreifen der bundestag ist
der meinung jörges der meinung zweimal
ist der meinung ich halte mich jetzt
hier mal raus was meine meinung ist aber
da ist natürlich die sache die umfragen
stimmen dass 50 prozent der bürger nicht
der auffassung sind mit den schülern
darüber die großen stimmen nicht tut
sich allerdings noch unter
umfrage ist 50 prozent dagegen 42 dafür
aber der punkt ist ja der wie wird man
überhaupt alle bürger abholen können
sowohl als journalist als auch als joker
dabei ich glaube jeder ist japan gerne
an dich können wir denn auch ein atom
krieg ausbrechen also theoretisch kann
natürlich alles passieren aber ich
glaube wenn wir angst und sorge und
angst und bange sind dann sind wir
schlecht beraten von da ist das die
falsche strategie ich glaube werden wir
darüber sprechen was möglich ist und
olaf scholz im bundestag sagt er tut
alles was möglich ist dann ist das
falsch das muss ja erst mal festhalten
das ist das erste das zweite wenn man
der überzeugung ist dass wir weniger
waffen liefern sollten dann sollte man
das auch erklären aber olaf scholz
erklärt einfach viel zu wenig
kommuniziert zu wenig und nimmt so die
bevölkerung nicht mit und ich glaube
deswegen gibt es eine große
verunsicherung meiner meinung nach gibt
es diese verunsicherung auch weil nicht
genügend erklärt wird warum schwere
waffen notwendig sind weil er zaudert
verzögert weil er erst diese sache ins
spiel gebracht hat und gesagt hat wenn
wir schwere waffen liefern dann drohe
ein atomkrieg das hat er damals im
spiegel interview gesagt sind gemäss um
dann ein paar tage später aber doch ein
bisschen schwerer waffen zu liefern also
ich glaube ist es vor allem momentan was
olaf scholz angeht und die regierung
angeht ein großes kommunikationsproblem
denn man kann sehr leicht erklären warum
es auch aus deutscher strategischer
sicht richtig ist schwere war für sie
locker industriefetten und da sind
spornt geliefert worden ist ja noch gar
nichts an schneidern versprochen worden
aber es sei also das wurde zumindest ein
panzer abwehr dinge wurden dann
geliefert dass es nicht genug das stimmt
wissen wir gar nicht was alles geliefert
wurde von neuer da sieht es ja leute im
verteidigungsausschuss die schon
informiert werden das wird nur das
versprochen was nicht sofort lieferbar
ist das ist der punkt ich glaube es gibt
eine verborgene agenda des kanzleramts
des bundeskanzlers und vermutlich auch
von herrn mack und dem französischen
präsidenten
die russen nicht daran zu hindern durch
schwere waffen die den donners komplett
zu besetzen um dann zu sagen darauf zu
hoffen auch dass putin sagt jetzt habe
ich ein ergebnis erreicht mit dem ich
mich sehen lassen kann die ganze ukraine
krieg ich nicht und jetzt reden wir über
waffenstillstand und frieden das ist für
mich die verborgene agenda von henk und
ingrid ist diese verborgene agenda die
muss also verborgen sagen weil ich ich
habe sehr viel übrig spekulationen von
journalisten ich kann nur feststellen es
gibt einen beschluss des deutschen
bundestags der auch die regierung bindet
so schnell wie möglich schweres gerät
ukraine zu schaffen findet nicht statt
und das norder wir haben bereits im märz
hatte zugleich gesagt die haben vier
wochen gewartet wir gucken uns das mal
eine marie agnes strack zimmermann
gesagt wir kommen im sommer bis ende
juni an dann brauchen wir eine erklärung
warum das was möglich ist nicht das also
sie hat das ja als ultimatum verpackt
obwohl ich gegen multi marten bin raus
starke zimmermann habe herzlich panzer
für mit herr jörges ich halte ich halte
auch ich halte es auch für für nahezu
fahrlässig zu erklären dass gibt es eine
heimliche agenda von westlichen staaten
doch ein wesentlicher teil der ukraine
durch russland erobern zu lassen ohne
was dagegen zu tun ein der hoffnung in
der hoffnung dass man dann einen
längeren frieden sichern kann diese
hoffnung auf zuverlässigkeit der russin
hat sich mit dem einmarsch der russen
ukraine komplett erledigt nur früher nur
sofern eigentlich sagen ich sage spät
also spätestens mit dem einmarsch bei
mir mit dem einmarsch in die ukraine hat
sich das erledigt und deshalb ist ein
vertrauen darauf dass wir einen
waffenstillstand hinbekommen der längere
zeit andauert naiv das wird dazu führen
dass die russischen kräfte wieder wieder
mobilisieren sammeln und dann aber es
auch im zweifel nichts nützen würde die
ukraine mit waffen auszustatten denn die
russen haben aus dem erstmaligen
angriff auf kiew massiv gelernt dass sie
mit anderen taktischen vorgehen würden
und was folgt daraus für ihr leben
fortführen daraus dass man darauf hoffen
dass die ukraine wurde rausschmeißt das
ist eine illusion dass sich das
irgendwann das sehen sie was befähigt
werden die russen einen
verhandlungstisch zu zwingen weil die
russen mit ihren möglichkeiten auch
nicht weiterkommen momentan ist es so
alles was die russen
kapitulation der ukraine dann ist es da
gibt es keinen krieg mehr ist ja logisch
weiße fahne hissen dann ist vorbei dann
würden sie aber trotzdem ihre
einflusszonen in der ukraine gewinnen
dann hätten wir insgesamt nichts
gewonnen die pläne schon gar nichts und
ich glaube wir sollten davon abstand
nehmen der ukraine zu erklären was wir
glauben dass sie tun oder lassen sollten
wenn die ukraine sagt wir brauchen jetzt
verteidigungsfähigkeit und wir sagen wir
wollen ihnen helfen ihre souveränität zu
bewahren dann müssen wir dazu beitragen
dass ihre verteidigungsfähigkeit
hersteller ich würde einmal die lage
ganz gewollt war sowohl für alle am
tisch uli einmal ganz kurz einige vater
einblenden die uns vielleicht paul
ronzheimer einmal kurz erklären kann
damit wir alle einmal auch abgeholt
werden wie wahrscheinlich denn auch noch
einen sieg der ukraine ist paul
vielleicht kannst du einmal dort
entstand erneut dass die frage so zu
sagen was man was ich so niederlage
definiert genau richtig also das erste
ziel eben großstädte zu europa kiew
sieht man dort nicht das ist weiter
links aber auch den in prosa politischer
oder hak i sind gescheitert was momentan
passiert das sieht man dort auf der
karte bei slogans und grammaturen das
ist auch die region aus der ich
zurückgekehrt bin dort gibt es massive
geländegewinne von städten zwischen
10.000 und 30.000 limans zum beispiel
ist eine stadt die sieht man dort nicht
aber das nächste ziel wird florians
seien im übrigen eine stadt die bekannt
geworden ist dadurch dass 2014 die von
russland unterstützten separatisten
diese stadt als erstes angenommen haben
und das ziel der russischen soldaten ist
dort einen kleinen kessel zu schließen
und sagen zu können man hat lugansk und
don was erobert und das wäre dann
tatsächlich etwas was man der russischen
bevölkerung als vermeintlichen sieg
verkaufen kann denn die propaganda läuft
dort seit jahren in einer richtung dass
man sagt angeblich würden die ukraine
den dollars angreifen und dort
kriegsverbrechen durch finden was eine
absolute lüge ist von daher würde das
aber sozusagen verfangen in der
russischen bevölkerung
ja also ich muss sagen anders wir hatten
das ja heute auch im
verteidigungsausschuss in der
sondersitzung und auch im auswärtigen
ausschuss gab es ja auch eine bnd
unterrichtung anders als medial
dargestellt wurde kann man ja eigentlich
schon alleine von der karte aussehen
dass das russische militär langsam aber
stetig fortschritte macht so das wurde
erst mal anders dargestellt was wir
alles erzählt bekommen haben hier sehr
schlecht aufgestellt und so weiter also
genau wie möglich soll der außenminister
lavrov hat gesagt es ist absolute
priorität ist denn bombers einzunehmen
den gesamten donnerstag
folgende frage stellen sie sagen zu
recht natürlich ist man solidarisch und
leidet ja auch mit mit der bevölkerung
in der ukraine aufgrund dieses
angriffskrieges aber die frage ist doch
trotzdem was es verantwortungsbewusstes
handeln hier ist es das dass man mehr öl
ins feuer gießt durch mehr schwere
waffen in diesen krieg zu schicken oder
ob man jetzt alles unternimmt um eine
eine eskalation um eine eskalation
eigenen eigene direkte direkte gefahr
entschuldigen sie herr kubicki aber dass
selbst der us-präsident beiden hat in
seinem eigenen meinungsbeitrag im
kindergarten begleichen auch zucker
darauf hingewiesen warum sie keine
kampfflugzeuge und keine panzer liefern
und auch die diskussion um die mehrfach
raketen hat er selber angesprochen
das könnte zu einer eskalation führen
könnte zur vergeltungsmaßnahmen der
russen führen die haben ja auch heute
darauf reagiert und haben gesagt dass
sie eventuell eben das als öl ins feuer
gießen sehen und es gibt natürlich diese
eskalationspotenzial gibt es weil die
eskalation dominanz in der ukraine in
diesem krieg bei russland liegt wir
wollen so bald wird sie den
gastbeiträgen anschauen im wortlaut bei
so genau also um es einmal ganz genau so
ganz genau zu zeigen also so beinhart
einmal nämlich in der new york times
gesagt amerikas ziel ist klar wir wollen
eine demokratische unabhängige souveräne
und wohlhabende ukraine mit den mitteln
um weitere aggression abzuwehren und sie
gegen sind zu verteidigen und hier haben
wir jetzt diesen satz den sie
wahrscheinlich meinten dass kein krieg
zwischen der nato und russland gewollt
ist und dass sie auch unter der zweite
satz ist dass sie auch so sehr sehr
putin nicht zustimmen und seine handlung
als empörung empfinden die vereinigten
staaten nicht versuchen werden seinen
sturz herbeizuführen aber in dem
gastbeitrag für stunden nicht dass man
nichts machen soll das heißt ja auch
nicht
ich habe sogar eine kampfflugzeuge und
keine panzer von den usa bisher
geliefert worden sind genau im glas
karlsruhes gefahr sehen das sieht die us
administration und das sieht auch die
bundesregierung offensichtlich auch wenn
sie das selber beschlossen hat und das
möchte für den fall das herr jörges ja
recht hat dass sie das bewusst nicht
machen und vielleicht noch andere
staaten und ich finde dass wenn
überhaupt denn wenn die ich das
eigentlich richtig dass man das nicht
macht weil es uns ja viel mehr in einen
krieg mit hineinzieht aber wie wollen
sie hier ist kreation schaffen was muss
aber irgendwas macht ja wirklich
fassungslos bei denen die einzelnen
eskalieren sind sind die russen die
russen marschieren weiter und dann sagen
sie wir wollen dem ukrainer keine
möglichkeit geben das supertalent da
können sie sagen da könnte ich gleich
aufgeben kubicki sehen sie nicht dass es
eine eskalationsgefahr birgt wenn wir
noch mehr schwere waffen durch die
ausbildung an diesen schweren waffen der
ukrainischen soldaten zum beispiel auch
kriegs beteiligte werden wie der
wissenschaftliche dienst des bundestages
geschafft sehen sie diese gefahr ich
sehe die eskalation gefallen sie sehen
auch die ja wahr das hab ich da auch die
aber auch die gefahr dass die russen
werden wenn ihnen nichts entgegengesetzt
nicht zu stoppen sein werden die werfen
vakuum bomben diversen phosphorbombe
firma wollen sie bis wohin wollen sie
waffen liefern so irgendeine atommacht
herr kubicki das geht auch nicht mehr
thomas geht darum dass die ukraine die
lage versetzt wird konventionell die
russischen vor die vordringen russische
truppen auch am sonntag auf ihren star
und die gegen tatsächlich das
konventionell mir durch immer mehr
aufrüstung der ukraine wir gegen so eine
macht dort tatsächlich einen sieg das
hat man aber nicht gesehen das hat man
auch gesehen dass hat man den tag
gesehen haben dass man weiter sehen dass
wenn das kriegt man wir haben ja sagen
nach hause schicken und sagen die russen
dürfen morgen berlin besetzt nein das
sei alles an
ein ich sage ihnen dass wir in einen
krieg hineinschlittern wenn wir uns
immer mehr mit schweren waffen und der
ausbildung an den soldaten an diesem
schweren einmal bei der frau vielleicht
sogar noch mehr an hilfen machen ich
sage die eskalation dominanz sie haben
mich missverstand ich sag ja gerade dass
die inne bei russland liegt aber weil
diese dominanz eben bei russland liegt
müssen wir aufpassen was sie dazu sage
nochmal wir sind nicht im krieg
herrnsheimer sie scheinen ja mental im
krieg zu sein ja aber wir sind nicht im
krieg gegen russland das möchte aber
das ist zu unter 30 haben angerichtet
habe mit dem wir gemeinsam
das sicher nicht
ich habe da besser waren sie von
siegfried
einmal nach es geht doch darum mit wir
meine ich die westliche gemeinschaft die
nato wenn wir einfach akzeptieren dass
russland die ukraine die
ukraine überfallen hat angegriffen hat
die tausende menschen ermordet hat die
kriegsverbrechen wie ein buddha
angerichtet hat wenn wir einfach sagen
okay lassen wir das geschehen denn ohne
die usa insbesondere ohne die usa hätte
kiew nicht bestehen können das ist doch
ganz klar das heißt wir müssen die
ukraine in die lage versetzen sich gegen
einen kriegsverbrechen und gegen einen
kriegsverbrecher zu wehren und wenn wir
das nicht tun so wie sie das nämlich
fordert sie sagen ja wir sollen keine
waffen wir sollen keine heilige eva
ihnen bleiben kriege ich nicht weil ihr
nein denn wenn wir das tun was in sachen
werden wir das tun was wir sagen dann
werden noch ganz viele butscher
passieren dann sind ins mikro menschen
ermordet das ist das so werden wie am
wagen wurde und wo das ziel am ende vor
hast du was sie am ende fordern bedeutet
das nach hausen dem haarschnitt werden
von ihren russischen nachbarn sie nicht
von ihren russischen firma tausende
menschen am ort ich weiß auch nicht
woran das ist hier niveau herunter
vielleicht habe ich noch darauf
hinweisen der hundertste erklärung als
die ukraine ihre hat er darum alle vier
mächte des weltsicherheitsrats russland
frankreich großbritannien und auch china
die territoriale integrität der ukraine
vertraglich versprochen da diese
territorien dieser vertrag ist gebrochen
worden ja an russland jetzt ist die
spannende frage
worauf will man sich nochmal einlassen
wenn dieses versprechen an die ukraine
wir helfen euch für den fall dass sie
angegriffen werden wenn das nicht
eingehalten wird was würden wir denn
machen wenn jetzt russische truppen weil
wir auch eine russisch sprechende
bevölkerung den baltischen staaten haben
estland litauen und da ist nicht die
angst wirklich vorhanden ich war da die
angst wirklich folgen dort
einmarschieren würden werden auch sagen
bevor wir ein atomkrieg riskieren sollen
sie lieber bis an die ostsee
weiter marschieren und anschließend
machen wir den frieden zweite land in
ost berlin noch kurz da wäre auch nicht
so schlimm kontaktieren oder wenn die
russen dann hier in hausen ich glaube
nicht glaube dass ich absolut über
bedrohungen eskalation zu reden ich habe
es von anfang an ein fehler gehalten
auch was die furcht angeht vor der
anderen seite von russland dass die nato
sich vor russland fürchtet aber russland
nicht vor der nato das finde ich schon
mal sehr merkwürdig ich halte es für
einen schweren strategischen fehler der
nato von anfang an erklärt zu haben wir
wollen in die auseinandersetzung in der
ukraine nicht verstrickt werden das muss
man offen halten in einer mit dahin die
nato sein verteidiger 7 ist für die
mitglieder für nichts anderes
entschuldigung ist kein gras und aber
wirklich und moment nicht verteidigt mit
den waffen die von der nato kommen da
wird die nato nicht verteidigt den den
punkt aber überschritten lässt er seinen
hut wie es hin gegriffen wir sind dabei
einen aggressor aufzuhalten der auch zur
bedrohung für die nato werden kann aber
mich interessiert in dem zusammenhang
die nato kann ich von mir aus muss das
gar nicht so laufen dann gibt es eben
eine eine koalition der willigen die die
ukraine unterstützen wenn die ungarn
sagen wann sind dabei noch alleine wir
müssen auf jeden fall muss die ukraine
instand gesetzt werden durch die waffen
die sie bekommt und wie kommt sie nicht
aus deutschland denn die kommen alle zu
spät vom vermutlich instand gesetzt
werden ab einem bestimmten punkt die
russischen truppen aufzuhalten definitiv
es ist doch erkennbar henry kissinger
hat sogar ausgesprochen weil es von den
westlichen politikern keiner sagt man
muss sich darauf einrichten dass
russland einen teil der ost ukraine und
der krim und weiter behält und nicht
mehr hergibt das halt ich umgekehrt war
der bei der man bei der meister der krim
da man für falsch halten umgekehrt
straße ist anstrengender job das vater
eine zweite seite dann jede seite hat
einen plan b der ukraine wird es auch
nicht gelingen die russischen truppen
daraus zu werfen denn da hat frau
dagdelen rechts ist eine atommacht das
lassen sie mich bieten irgendwas hinter
die linie des 24 februar auf den
lärmpegel ausgesetzt hat sagte meinhardt
die werden auch eine wahrheit ist ein
tagen und wochen sagt er das ziel das er
selber sagt jeden tag varianten jahres
das ziel ist momentan festgelegt die
russischen truppen hinter die linie des
24 februar also sozusagen vor dem großen
krieg der russen gegen das hat er
darüber gehören ist auch ein teil der
ukraine verloren mir geht es um die
andere seite plan b der ukraine ist ja
nicht kann nicht mehr sein die
russischen truppen komplett aus der
ukraine rauszuwerfen natürlich musste
das wird nicht gelingen also die die
krim frei zu machen und die ost ukraine
komplett frei ist eine illusion das
heißt die ukraine muss sich darauf
konzentrieren ab wann beginnt die
ukraine ab welchen grenzen die wir die
eu führen wollen und die sich westlich
orientiert und das muss auch unser
nachdenken sein und da muss die ukraine
in stand gesetzt werden durch schwere
waffen aber und isis territorium zu
verteidigen ist das ganze immer noch
realistisch zu betrachten und zu sagen
im moment aber wenn man sich sozusagen
bleiben putin an schaut und sagt dass er
handeln nach irgendeiner logik dann muss
man ja davon ausgehen dass diese
irgendwo fest gesetzt ist und all das
was war dem putin getan hat hatte er
angekündigt in einem magazinbeitrag in
verschiedenen interviews häusern zu
kriegsbeginn und dieses ziel von
wladimir putin lautet eben nicht zu
sagen wie ich nehme teile des donners
und höre dann auf sondern das ziel ist
dass die ukraine und hier besteht aber
mal ganz kurz aussprechen bitte einmal
halb geschlagen ganz cool also ändert
das ändern nicht aus nein das ändert
nicht alles weil es bedeuten würde
dieser krieg der seit 2014 im osten
passiert könnte pausiert werden für
wenige jahre vielleicht ich mir putin
möglicherweise würden sanktionen
zurückgefahren könnte erneut aufrüsten
und würde kehrt wieder angreift aus zu
schneien das ist nicht nur nicht
auszuschließen sondern sehr
wahrscheinlich wenn wir so handeln mit
seiner kaputten armee die heute hat wir
haben noch ein bisschen was
gelernt
lasst mich den satz bitte noch sagen
dass die annahme die russische armee sei
ums fünffache überlegen der ukraine das
zehnfache und werde innerhalb von drei
tagen erobert sich ja nicht um die sache
sondern um die reifen des der
hardware hab ich auch die am besten wir
haben doch gesehen sie wo vielleicht
waffen und die rolle
daher kann ich so gut so
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter krach
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 14 85 köpfen sind meinungen
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt freut oder schockiert
so nicht
retten das auge ist aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur derart zu überlassen lasst den
leuten soll man den spaß wie sehen ja
etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in der
politik bei den journalisten deren job
ist es doch gerade abweichende meinungen
zu finden und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig dürfte sein dass wegen eines
quasi zum manko vielleicht einmal kurz
an dann werden wir ganz nennen doch das
eigentliche handlung radträger
ausgesprochen in bewegung bringen ich
habe meinen beifall über eine sache
immer bekommen er kümmert sich darum
niemand ist bei federer noch ist er ganz
klein auch darüber sprechen dass einfach
nicht fertig richtig wo ist die aufgabe
von journalismus einfach
die verlautbarung der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wahnsinnig sachlich diskutieren
wir sind zurück und will kommen und
bleiben bei unserer ausgangs frage wie
der konflikt zu lösen ist der krieg zu
lösen ist und ich würde hier direkt
gerne einmal ein paar ronzheimer die
frage stellen wie die aktuelle lage ist
wohl jetzt noch einmal ab bevor wir
weiter debattieren ja ich glaube das
große problem für die ukraine ist eben
im osten wir leben da seit wochen ein
langsames aber durchaus stetiges
vorrücken russlands was auch in den
medien in den vergangenen zwei wochen
zumindest genauso beschrieben wurde das
problem der ukraine dort vor ort ist
fehlende artillerie bislang fehlende
munition und fehlende schwere waffen
wenn man jetzt von kampfpanzern ausgeht
die ukraine das sagen sie würde gerne
gegen offensive neben auch in diesen
gebieten staaten gegen die russische
armee dafür bräuchte ist aber zum
beispiel mader zum beispiel andere
panzer mit dem man vorrücken kann und
momentan ist man die ganze zeit in einem
verteidigungs modus und das problem oder
die große sorge ist eben dass russland
lugansk und donners komplett erobern
dritte und das wäre wirklich das wäre
doch nun hat was ihr möglich und ist auf
einer der vielen aus fehlt nicht mehr
viel muss man sagen wobei es noch
einzelne städte in wiesloch jahns und
andere in dieser region gibt die nicht
besetzt sind von der russischen armee
aber wenn das passiert dann wäre putins
ziel was den osten angeht und das wäre
das ziel wovon viele experten
ausgegangen waren vor dem krieg wenige
haben damit gerechnet dass er
tatsächlich die hauptstadt angreifen
würde aber viele waren davon ausgegangen
dass er dort das muss man den zuschauern
erklären wo seit 2014 im krieg herrscht
gebiets eroberungen macht viele erhoffen
sich natürlich dass der krieg beendet
ist gibt es dennoch die möglichkeit der
verhandlungen zwischen den leidigen
putin und würde mehr sinn es diese
möglichkeiten gibt es das sagt würde
müsse lenski immer wieder selbst er sagt
aber ich möchte mit wladimir putin
verhandeln er sagt wir müssen an einem
tisch sitzen wladimir putin akzeptiert
ja nicht einmal telefongespräch auch
vorher hat er nie mit selensky
telefoniert er akzeptiert die nicht als
präsidenten er wollte ihn ja ermorden
lassen in den ersten wochen als er kiew
angegriffen hat und das problem bei den
verhandlungen weil das ist ja auch eine
mehr und eine lüge die immer wieder
erzählt wird dass die ukraine angeblich
dort abgebrochen hätten weil der westen
druck gemacht hätte das ist vollkommener
blödsinn es ging damals um butter also
es gab die verhandlungen ist dann wohl
dann ist passiert wo mehrere hundert
menschen
zivilisten ermordet hingerichtet wurden
und daraufhin hat die ukrainische
delegation zu diesem zeitpunkt die
verhandlungen abgebrochen das bedeutet
nicht dass es diese fahndung nicht geben
wird das rc lens die immer wieder gesagt
er hat gesagt am ende müssen wir
verhandeln und natürlich weiß der
ukrainische präsident dass dort
schwierige gespräche sicherlich auch
schwere kompromisse auf ihn zukommen
werden und das natürlich große teile
dessen was russland jetzt besetzt hat
zumindest in der nahen zukunft nicht
mehr möglicherweise von der ukraine so
schnell befreit werden hat doch erkannt
dass seine armee viel schlechter ist als
er gedacht hat viel schlechter er ist
nicht gelungen kiew überhaupt noch
wirkungsvoll anzugreifen geschweige denn
ein zu nehmen und in die westukraine
vorzustoßen auch nicht gelungen was
heißt dass das was er jetzt mit dieser
armee erreichen kann ist noch die
arrondierung der ost ukraine und das
war's dann ich glaube auch dass ihm der
westen das deutlich gesagt hat dann ist
schluss das kannst du noch machen da
können wir noch einen politischen deal
machen du kriegst du ost ukraine weil
die ukraine selbst die west ukraine das
lässt der westen auch nicht mehr zu dass
putin da noch mal reingeht und an seinem
ziel fest hält die ukraine vollständig
zu erobern das erreicht er nicht mehr
das ist auch hier im besten keinem
menschen zu erklären dass dann
irgendwelche flugabwehrsysteme geliefert
werden aber keine panzer hat die auf der
erde schießen das thema ist vorbei das
thema ist jetzt putin wand ist ja das
war ja es ist klasse glaubt lesern in
den vergangenen wochen dass er plan
vielleicht im jahr also auch japan zu
tragen also wenn wenn als auch was den
russischen staatsfernsehen auch gefühlt
nicht leute die sagen nicht jetzt müssen
wir mal richtig reinhauen und jetzt muss
die russische armee mal zeigen was sie
wirklich kann die diese schmach dass wir
am besten dauernd über diskutieren die
können nichts das lastet sehr stark auf
arbeit da sie sich auch schon jetzt
erkennbar da war es doch da der
teilweise noch einmal sagen wir reden ja
auch darüber dass da ein land dann
besetzt wird
völkerrechtswidrig besetzt wird in dem
auch menschenleben die da nicht
sozusagen russischen wesen als
russischer sprache zu neigen also wir
reden auch über immer noch
hunderttausende von menschen geben indem
ich denen sagen tut uns leid
beziehungs lager mit wir hier in
deutschland leben das ich jetzt hier hat
überlegungen aus aber dann eben auch
sehr viele russisch orientierte das darf
man nicht vergessen dass der ganze und
der andere ursprung dieses verflixte da
auch keine dass diejenigen die west den
westlichen denkens aus nach hause ja zu
hause hat ist lege meine hand nicht da
bin ich euer wie lange eine solche
lösung hält daher unsere monster sind
sehr viel das können wir aus der
geschichte europas des 20
das muss noch viele aber der hat ja herr
jörges recht dass da gerade im osten der
ukraine
viele sind die sich zugehörig fühlen
russland würde
das merkwürdig dass wir immer in dieser
militärischen logik
festbeißen uns in den diskussionen ich
finde was die ukraine braucht ist eine
perspektive und da komme ich halt
mal folgt bestimmt wieder was wir jetzt
sozusagen wie kann hier auch die
bundesrepublik deutschland helfen um so
schnell wie möglich und so gut wie
möglich den frieden zu gewinnen weil
darum geht es nicht den krieg gewinnen
wir wollen frieden
natürlich aber das macht ja was machen
schwere waffen es geht darum wie ich
ihnen von anfang an gesagt habe kriege
werden durch verhandlungen beendet
möchte ich
auch meine herrnsheimer meint dass gar
die in washington post und so weiter
alle blödsinn schreiben oder sich
gelohnt hatte die zitate sind ja alle da
die berichte dass natürlich boris
johnson torpediert hat auch er hat den
verhandlungsfrieden torpediert und aus
den usa gab es das erzählen sie wieder
diesen handeln fordert diese wahrheit
dass ich auch auf den reinen schon klar
wo das geschriebene vor wir erst einmal
zurück dorthin kommen und ich glaube 1
meine vermutung ist dass man zu dem
zeitpunkt eigentlich gedacht hat man
könnte weil die vorherrschende meinung
war das ist so schlecht aufgestellt das
russische militär die kriegen keinen
stich hier und deshalb können wir die
eigentlich besiegen dafür auch
angefangen von siegfried zu sprechen und
ich denke das ist sozusagen man gedacht
hat wir wollen jetzt kein
verhandlungsfrieden dass man sollte ja
auch nicht vorschnell also hier zum
beispiel united kingdom großbritannien
hat gesagt wir wollen keine vorschnellen
frieden haben und deshalb glaube ich
dass es das gibt es nicht das tor steht
in der ukrainischen traf da wo boris
johnson da in kiew war mit senesie
gesprochen hat
na ja es wurde ja dieses zitat nicht
widersprochen haben wir haben wir haben
wir haben
finden die die ukraine muss in die lage
versetzt werden haben wir auch kein sieg
zufrieden durch
aber ich will ihnen nur sagen russland
wird auch kein diktat frieden
akzeptieren da sind jungs mit russland
unter haslam solaris und was machen als
auch ein bildreporter wie jacques
schuster regina seines mega diktat
frieden für ukraine noch diktat friebe
russland ein arbeiter mit fragen ein
schaffen wir den kopf
über
die deutsche politik vielleicht auch
noch über die französische oder die
westeuropäischen müssen und was herrn
präsident weiß ich nicht aber ich weiß
dass wir der ukraine keiner in drei
monaten krieg keine einzige schwere
waffe geliefert haben weil wir uns nicht
wollten das kanzleramt wollte es nicht
die beiden koalitionspartner muss ich
leider das angucken zu frau strack
zimmermann wird jetzt aufsässig bot
lobmeier also und den grünen und die
grüne haben aufsässig habe er sehen die
sache sowieso ganz anders und es ist
doch gar nicht wahr dass es keine
schweren waffen gibt sie nicht sofort
geliefert werden könnten natürlich
könnten sofort marder panzer in großer
zahl geliefert werden die zur
verteidigung der ost ukraine eingesetzt
werden jetzt wo es notwendig ist
nicht flugabwehrsysteme die im herbst
geliefert werden das klingt vielleicht
längst zu ende wir geben eben er den
vorwurf ja auch ein herrn kubicki weiter
dass auch fdp einfach zuschaut und man
sofort leider aufgehört zuzuschauen aber
bis hin zur ultimativen
journalisten dieses mal ausleihen mengen
sagen wir schicken jetzt 60 meter in die
ukraine der nächste krieg hat ihre
partei kann ich ja immer alles in
ordnung wir sagen diese die sagt nur wir
könnten marder liefern einsatz in rüssen
des sollten können und wir müssen nach
dem beschluss des deutschen bundestages
müssen wir uns eigentlich tun ich bin
wie gesagt habe da ja und da gibt es
eine beschlusslage die an die regierung
auch gebunden ist aber was so aus allem
zu sagen wir schicken jetzt auch leopard
dahin möglicher parteien die
ukrainischen soldaten auch fahren ist
genauso also werden panzer fahren kann
leopard 2 können sie nicht bedienen weil
er so viel elektronik dahin hat da musst
du geschult werden ja wir schicken
lieber schrott parat meister sowjetzeit
dahin über ringtausch geschäfte die dann
wieder zwei drei monate dauern das ist
doch ein skandal also erstens bin ich
immer dafür dass wir die ihnen die
unmittelbar italien sind darüber
entscheiden lassen was sie wollen und
was sie brauchen und da wir uns
entschieden haben ihnen das zu liefern
was sie brauchen bis auf flugzeuge
unsere fliegen ja auch nicht rum wir
müssen ja auch welche panamericana
bestellen und bis auf systeme die
russische territorium erreichen können
sollten wir das was möglich ist
tatsächlich auch tun und wir sollten
nicht über die ukraine hinweg
entscheiden was ist weckt an die russen
ja das will ich sowieso nicht aber die
ukraine hätte auch gerne marder panzern
hat sechs mal gesagt und keine werden
geliefert ja die können wir jetzt
hinstellen manchmal autoindustrie
bestand hat wenn wir keine munition der
firmen nutzen die marder panzer auf
platz andrea waren wir nicht im jahr
macht um 1,3 millionen schuss munition
gibt es
im moment nicht schießen wir wohl sagen
die ganzen rest die ukraine will was wir
für die ukraine wollen was natürlich
auch wichtig ist aber die deutsche
politik und die die minister deutschland
wir haben ja auch genau was deutschland
will und sie wollen ja auch schaden vom
deutschen volk abhalten kann es deswegen
ich auch sein dass die entscheidung von
olaf scholz nicht direkt zu handeln auch
etwas mit seiner besorgnis um
deutschland zu tun hat dass ich
wiederhole noch mal wild aber jetzt
nicht ausführen dass ich glaube es gibt
eine verborgene agenda aber die
öffentlich nicht geredet wird weil mir
die öffentlich gar nicht darstellen kann
das traut sich eben keiner zu sagen
entscheide der ukraine ist verloren so
und olaf scholz ist kanzler eigentlich
ist die zeit über olaf scholz schon
hinweggegangen es ist die ventile als
ein jahr im amt moment wenn die ukraine
frage die zentrale frage dieser zeit ist
dann ist der sozialdemokratische kanzler
olaf scholz überholt denn er ist ihr
nicht gewachsen also wir haben von einer
zeitenwende gehört die hat er selber
nicht vollzogen die deutsche diese
koalition hat sie nicht vollzogen und
dann muss man darüber nachdenken
probleme suchen sich die iren ihnen
gemäßen regierungen dann ist es zeit
über ein regierungswechsel nachzudenken
und den überdenken die wahrscheinlich
sowieso laufend nach frau stark
zimmermann und ein paar grüne dann ist
es zeit irgendwann den stöpsel zu ziehen
und dann muss herr scholz eben in die
opposition gehen guten haben
journalisten wir drei tage was das
schreibe ich halte das für eine völlig
falsche herangehensweise wenn wir zu
einer lösung kommen wollen und die
ukraine darauf bestehen dass wir an
möglichen frieden garantieren dann
müssen wir dann auch garantieren dass
wir wieder gebrochen wird militärisch
eingreifen und dann sind dann werd dann
werden welche waren feil wenn man wenn
man die ukraine garantiert das ist ja
eine der vorstellungen die ukraine wird
um die ost ukraine beraubt das geht den
russischen besitz über und die dann
verbleiben nur kleine gegen die eu und
wird garantiert in ihrem bestand aber
dann doch niemand
dann müssen die garantie möchte auch
militärisch dafür garantiert nicht
passieren
es geht doch darum was dem was nicht
passieren soll also bevor wir zu dieser
garantie macht kommen oder der
garantieerklärung brauchen wir erstmal
den frieden und das zweite ist wie
schaffen wir diesen frieden und dann
gab's ja sogar vorschläge vom
ukrainischen präsidenten selbst nämlich
über die neutralität der ukraine zu
sprechen über den dom was zu sprechen
eigentlich nach -2 sozusagen über eine
autonomie der dom bass regionen das wäre
sozusagen vorteilhafter als das was im
moment status quo ist und über die krim
und ich finde darüber sollte man doch
reden man sollte diese möglichkeiten
doch eröffnen
nein das problem ist doch wir wer was
macht die deutsche politik da der jörges
recht was macht die deutsche politik die
deutsche politik sollte versuchen
zusammen mit makro am besten eine
diplomatische offensive
zu starten ist es ja auch gut wenn man
redet miteinander
aber man muss auch gucken dass man beide
seiten irgendwie aber es haben sich
sofort um frontmann ist vor formuliere
rät man muss den kopf schließlich
proform hören was passiert im moment
nicht doch
denn wenn olaf scholz und emanuel
markierung gemeinsam mit putin
telefonieren dann reden die nicht nur um
die um die weizen versorgung nordafrika
seien geht es um viel kraft wie tagen
natürlich aber auch nicht jetzt haben
wir jetzt wollen wir das feld nicht
eröffnen dann geht es darum endlich wenn
die zu dritt miteinander reden geht es
um substanzielle fragen dann geht es
genau um die frage wann ist der punkt
erreicht wo ein waffenstillstand
verkündet werden muss und verkünden
müssen in die russen die ukraine können
den nicht anbieten das muss putin tun
und deshalb reden die auf finale noch
einmal es gibt wenig logisch in anbieten
warum die leute im ausland daran halten
die machen sie hatten offensichtlich
doch so arm ist eine auf klein hält das
ist nicht mehr zu glauben dann kannst du
alles aufgeben alles aufgeben wie wir es
bräuchten bräuchten wir für das sei
wirklich der der 50 jahre seines lebens
in spannungsvollen zu tun gehört wird
wenn wir die russen vertrauen sollen
brauchen wir vertrauensbildende
maßnahmen die bestehe nicht darin nicht
dass das die ukraine gespräche anbieten
doris ahnen die machen wir nicht dass
keine vertrauensbildende russen die
russen müssten ihrerseits erklären wir
stoppen jetzt alle kampfhandlungen weil
wir vernünftigerweise zurück auf die
linie von gehen zurück auf die
24-jährige konflikt muss ich achten ob
vierfach angefahrenen waren ich diktiere
die bedingungen dann werden wir nicht
vorankommen herr kubicki ich habe das
niemals aber es ist doch ein anderer
nein ganz im gegenteil deshalb habe ich
ja auch die völkerrechtswidrige
anerkennung von kosovo was sie ja
mitgemacht habe mit ihrer partei auch
nicht gut gefunden als ich sage
völkerrecht muss für alle gelten nicht
nur für eine seite wir sind uns ja alle
an diesem tisch geeinigt dass dies ein
angriffskrieg ist beachtenswert ist und
zu verurteilen ist ja aber das problem
ist es ist ein krieg und wie können wir
diesen krieg stoppen darum geht es doch
es geht nicht darum was ich mir wünsche
dir was habe sondern die rede sie täten
so wie sie sind
mit denen
man kann aber die un-charta mit dem
gewaltverbot nicht respektiert aber war
es die die schlussfolgerung kann alles
sein
das ist nie surprise wenn sie war ernst
nehmen würden ihren job würden sie
wissen dass wir immer für das
ja weil sein mögen dass wir immer für
ein völker für das völkerrecht sind
immer
gegen den krieg im irak und im all
verzögert sind und immer noch
verharmlosen was wo sondern und die
meist zum
probieren sachlichen und ich glaube ein
anderes thema anschneiden wir leben in
dem dilemma dass wir versuchen müssen
einen ein abkommen mit russland zu
schließen also die ukraine muss das tun
aber das ist ohne den westen nehmen
müssen wo alle miteinander lernen sich
auf ein abkommen
einigen im selben moment wo der fluss
enz gehalten hatte um mit den russen ja
das haben wollten die beiden nicht so
richtig weil das auf ihn zukommen hat
ist jedenfalls verbrennt sobald des
geschlossenes wissen die ja nie wissen
wir auch dass dieses abkommen
höchst gefährdet ist und möglicherweise
gar nicht hält unter geschichtlichen
gesichtspunkten also wenn sich russland
einen teil der austria oder die gesamte
ost ukraine plus die krim plus den land
gürtel nach russland unter den nagel
reißt würde sind doch keine immer große
kräfte in der politik geben die sagen es
müssen uns zurückholen das heißt und
möglicherweise wird hier rollten in den
werken möglicherweise gibt es in
russland kräfte die sagen damit dürfen
uns nicht zufriedengeben wir müssen die
faschisten aus china vertreiben das
heißt du hast ständig wir deutsche
europäer haben es wahrscheinlich
möglicherweise auf 100 jahre mit dem mit
den spätfolgen dieses konflikts zu tun
und dennoch bewahrt uns das nicht davor
jetzt frieden herzustellen weil menschen
sterben das ist unsere aufgabe so und
wir jetzt noch mal die frage jetzt wie
soll der hergestellt werden indem wir
jetzt sagen wir beschließen die halbe
ihr sagen da haben wir sagen gar nix ich
glaube das gibt einen plan im kanzleramt
und in paris aber entscheidend sind sie
kleiner entscheidend sind die ukrainer
die müssen sich auf einen plan mit den
russen verständigen nach meinem
verständnis rückt der zeitpunkt näher wo
man darüber reden kann wo nämlich die
beide armeen sich erschöpft haben die
russen die ukraine die die ost ukraine
geholt haben und dann es sind ja aber
erst mal fertig und die die ukraine
wiederum kann das auch nicht mehr mit
voller wucht verteidigen sie brauchen
westlicher waffen deshalb bin ich sehr
dafür die zu liefern aber das dient nur
dazu zu verhindern dass die russen
weiter nach westen geht und dann ist der
punkt gekommen wo die beiden mit einer
reden müssen und natürlich gibt es von
den westlichen staaten einflussversuche
auf die ukraine sollen die das machen
sollen die was abgeben oder nicht
abgeben das weiß ich nicht wieder
argumentiert wird wie sieht das
washington wie sieht das berlin das
wären wir dann erleben sie spannende
frage ist wie sie das wieder ist er groß
ist wollte er sich als 6 uhr schlagen
die jacken mit diesen stoffen verlegt
was sie verschaffen das leben um ihre
reserven aufzufüllen wenn mitte juni
wieder aufzufüllen
mittlerweile ausgehenden raketen wieder
werden nach zu produzieren und dann
werden die nicht dastehen und sagen
reicht jetzt ja wir haben trotz
gehören die sendung ist zu ende die wir
sehr leidenschaftlich wird nicht zu
einer lösung gekommen doch vielleicht
morgen abend schön abend 80
[Musik]